Der Rasenfunk – Kurzpass. Und was ist los in La Liga? Es wird Zeit mal wieder nach Spanien zu gucken und wir tun das mit Fabian Pakulat, einem deutschen Sportjournalist, der in Spanien lebt und bei Twitter at rosengardler heißt. Fabian, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt willkommen im Rasenfunk.
Hallo Max, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Du lebst in Spanien, bist Sportjournalist. Was machst du denn da drüben?
Ja, ich bin hier mehr oder weniger zufällig gelandet als Erasmus-Student. Dann hat es mir hier sehr gut gefallen und habe dann noch die Chance bekommen, hier dann irgendwann mal als Sportjournalist tätig zu werden in Malaga. Und ja, und dann bin ich einfach hier geblieben, nicht?
Klar, so kann das im Erasmus ja auch mal gehen, ist doch auch schön. Wie kommst du denn zu dem Twitter-Händler Rosengardler? Da bin ich ein bisschen drüber gestolpert.
Ja, der Stadion des FC Malaga heißt La Rosaleda und wenn man das etwas flapsig übersetzt ins Deutsche, dann ist das der Rosengarten. Ich wollte immer der Rosengärtner sein, aber den gab es nicht mehr und so bin ich eben der Rosengardler geworden.
Besser als der Rosengradler oder der Rosengrandler, immerhin der Rosengardler.
Beim Rosengrandler, ja, war ich nahe dran, das auch zu nehmen, denn man kann auch oft mal sehr erzürnt werden, wenn es um den FC Malaga geht.
Und wie ist das so, als deutscher Sportjournalist in Spanien dann zu berichten? Was sind dann so die Medien, für die du Dinge machst?
Es gibt hier eine deutschsprachige Zeitung, eine Wochenzeitung, hier unten in Malaga oder an der Costa del Sol. Da leben ja ziemlich viele Deutsche, vor allen Dingen in der Ecke Marbella. Und dementsprechend schreibe ich für die. Habe dann aber auch das Glück, dass diese deutsche Zeitung zu einem großen spanischen Verlag gehört, die hier auch eine Tageszeitung haben. Und ja, teilweise konnte ich auch mit Radiosendern hier vor Ort kollaborieren. Also man kommt dann so ein bisschen rum, aber so das hauptsportliche Augenmerk ist dann meine deutsche Wochenzeitung.
Und findest du, der spanische Sportjournalismus unterscheidet sich vom deutschen?
Ja, es ist schon sehr, wie sagt man denn, so ein bisschen bildlastig hier. Wir haben ja in Spanien die auflagenstärksten Tageszeitungen, sind Sportzeitungen, sind Sportkazetten und keine, sage ich jetzt mal, normale Zeitungen mit Nachrichten. Dementsprechend ist eigentlich schon ziemlich klar, wie hoch hier der Standard ist oder wie hoch hier das Interesse ist an Sportnachrichten. Vor allen Dingen natürlich geht es immer um die großen Barca und Real Madrid. Klar, wenn man hier dann aber schon 12 oder 13 Jahre wie in meinem Fall lebt, dann kann einem das auch irgendwann mal auf den Zeiger gehen. Dass es immer nur um die beiden gibt, denn es gibt in Spanien noch ganz viele andere tolle Mannschaften und vor allen Dingen auch andere Sportarten. Und die Spanier sind sehr gut im Sport und es macht Spaß. Es gibt ein großes Feld, das man hier wirklich betrachten und über das man berichten kann.
Und wie ist dann die Art und Weise, wie man sich damit auseinandersetzt? Also klar, wenn man täglich über vor allem Barca und Real berichtet, da wird dann auch der Boulevard eine Rolle spielen. Aber italienischer Sportjournalismus zum Beispiel ist schon recht taktisch und dementsprechend auch das taktische Wissen bei den Fans recht hoch. Wie ist das in Spanien?
Ja, es kommt dann ein bisschen auf das Medium drauf an. Aber es geht schon eher in vielen Medien leider Richtung Soap Opera. Das wird hier halt am besten mal verkauft und dementsprechend hat man auch in normalen Nachrichtensendungen eigentlich, die täglich laufen, immer über Sport und da geht es dann immer über Barca und Real. Und da geht es dann meistens nicht um die taktischen Vorgaben vom letzten Wochenende, sondern wie der Messi die Haare schön hat und Bale lieber Golf als Fußball spielt und so. Also da werden ganz viele Schauplätze außerhalb des Rasens beleuchtet. Und es geht einem wirklich nur auf den Sport oder am Sportinteresse. Das kann ja nur so schnell mal auf den Zeiger gehen.
Na gut, dann wollen wir versuchen uns jetzt mal hier eher auf den Sport zu beschränken. Allerdings auch wir kommen jetzt nicht, zumindest am Anfang, an Barca und Real vorbei. Unter anderem auch deshalb, weil jetzt die Klassikowochos anstehen. Also wir haben jetzt zweimal El Klassico. Einmal hatten wir ihn gestern am Mittwochabend im Halbfinal-Rückspiel der Copa del Rey. Da hat Barca 3-0 in Madrid gewonnen. Können wir gleich drüber sprechen. Und dann werden wir es am Wochenende jetzt erleben am 26. Spieltag in La Liga, wo die beiden Teams wieder aufeinandertreffen und das Ganze auch in Madrid stattfindet. Gestern dieses Halbfinal-Rückspiel nach einem 1-1 im Hinspiel in Madrid, 14-4 Torschüsse für Real. Entschuldigung, 4-2 Torschüsse für Real. Und Barca hat es geschafft, aus zwei Torschüssen drei Tore zu machen, mit einem Eigentor von Varane und hat 3-0 gewonnen. Wie ist das passiert? Wie ist das möglich?
Ja, die Effizienz war natürlich auf Seiten der Katalanen. Das ist ganz klar gestern. Und Real Madrid stellt sich in den letzten Wochen leider immer wieder selbst ein bisschen an den Bein. Ich denke, der Trainerwechsel von Solari ist nicht ganz glücklich in der Hinsicht, dass er eigentlich mehr Kriegsschauplätze eröffnet hat, als geschlossen hat. Und es ist tatsächlich bei Real Madrid so, dass vorne die Effektivität fehlt. Da wurde ja auch einer verkauft im Sommer, der jedes Jahr 30 Tore gemacht hat. Das spürt man einfach. Und hinten ist es einfach so in der Defensive, dass vor allen Dingen auch Solari so ein paar harte Personalentscheidungen getroffen hat, die eben nicht so gut funktionieren. Dementsprechend tut sich Real im Moment sehr schwer, hat großartige Spiele vereint mit katastrophalen Aussetzern, vor allen Dingen in der Defensive. Und dementsprechend kommen sie nicht wirklich vom Fleck dieses Jahr.
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viele Spiele über 90 Minuten gesehen, das gestern konnte ich mir angucken. Da war sehr auffällig, nach vorne hin kann man Real den Vorwurf machen, die Chance nicht verwertet zu haben. Alleine, ich glaube, Vinicius hatte sechs Torschüsse, und das waren dann auch die meisten im ganzen Team. Ter Stegen hat da allerdings auch überragend gehalten, auf Seiten von Barcelona. Aber die Art und Weise, wie Barca mit eigentlich fast ausschließlich Umschaltsituationen innerhalb von wenigen Pässen vor dem Madridter Tor war, die hat mich schon irritiert. Ist das stellvertretend für die gesamte Saison, dass Real den Ball hat und auch durchaus Chancen, aber hinten ebenso offen steht?
Ja, so ein bisschen schon. Man hat auch so das Gefühl, dass so ein bisschen die Luft raus ist bei vielen Spielern. Wir erinnern uns ja alle an dieses großartige Mittelfeld, das eigentlich die Champions League mehr oder weniger die letzten drei Jahre, nicht immer Leingang gewonnen hat, aber großen Teil ausgemacht hat mit Casimiro, Kroos und Modric. Und wenn du dir die drei anschaust, vor allem den gestern, die sind platt. Davon siehst du nicht viel. Klar, die haben immer noch individuelle Klasse und können einen Passgut zum Mann bringen, aber die laufen bei Weitem nicht mehr so viel und so stark wie vielleicht noch vor letztem Jahr oder vor zwei Jahren. Ich glaube, das ist irgendwie auch eine Verschleißentscheidung. Und für Real Madrid ist genau dieses Mittelfeld eben ganz wichtig, denn ich denke mal vor allen Dingen die Außenverteidiger mit Carvajal oder gestern auch der junge Reguillon, der das zwar sehr gut gemacht hat, aber da fehlt es einfach auch an Erfahrung und offensiv kommt dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr weit über, aber defensiv sind die beiden jetzt auch nicht so ganz auf der Höhe. Und dementsprechend erkläre ich mir das so ein bisschen, dass bei Real Madrid das alles ein bisschen stagniert im Moment.
In der Liga sieht das dann so aus, dass man aktuell neun Punkte Rückstand auf Barca hat. Das heißt, es ist jetzt Must-Win-Game für Real zu Hause gegen Barca. Wie ordnest du denn die Chancen ein, das zu gewinnen? Wenn du jetzt sagst, die Luft ist ein bisschen raus, da habe ich ein bisschen aufgehäuft, weil in der Copa del Rey die war ja noch zu gewinnen. Und die Chancen hätten da gar nicht so schlecht gestanden, wenn man jetzt weiter gekommen wäre bis ins Finale. In der Liga sieht es ja tatsächlich schon schlechter aus für Real.
Absolut. Also ich meine, die Copa del Rey da ins Halbfinale zu kommen, ist nicht so schwer. Ich glaube, die großen Teams steigen erst im Achtelfinale ein. Also von daher war es jetzt für Real Madrid nicht so schwer, ins Halbfinale zu kommen. Ich meine, so die Luft ist eher so raus ein bisschen bei den Spielern. Die sind einfach vielleicht auch gesättigt. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Der Trainer schafft es auch nicht mehr, sie neu zu reizen. Und klar, Real Madrid ist natürlich auch ein großer Schauplatz mit vielen Medien, wo ständig darauf eingetroschen wird. Und dann ist Solari, wie gesagt, der Trainer, nicht so geschickt im Umgang mit einigen Spielern. Es gibt den Fall Isco, es gibt den Fall Marcello, die auf der Bank sitzen und gar nicht spielen. Und dementsprechend herrscht einfach viel zu viel Unruhe. Und in der Liga ist man sich eigentlich einig, auch bei sämtlichen spanischen Medien, dass das Ding durch ist, dass Barcelona sich die Butter nicht vom Brot nehmen lässt dieses Jahr. Obwohl sie gar nicht so überragend spielen wie ich finde, auch gestern nicht. Aber sie sind extrem effizient und haben da vorne immer noch diesen Messi, der, wenn es sein muss, den Unterschied machen kann.
Also ich hatte schon gehört, dass Isco eine streitbare Personalie bei Real ist. Die große Frage, warum spielt ein so talentierter Spieler so selten? Ich denke, jeder Fußballfan wird auch schon mitbekommen haben, dass es rund um Gareth Bale jetzt ja fast schon traditionell viel zu berichten gibt. Da hat er ja auch am letzten Ligaspiel wieder für Aufsehen gesorgt, indem er einfach sich zwischenzeitlich vom Aufwärmen wieder auf die Bank begeben hat und den Kepa gemacht hat, allerdings den Kepa leitet und einfach gesagt hat, ich habe jetzt keine Lust, mich weiter aufzuwärmen. Er wurde dann dennoch eingewechselt. Aber was ist denn bei Marcelo los? Das war mir bisher nicht so bewusst.
Ja, das ist eigentlich eine reine Trainer- oder taktische Entscheidung, angeblich zumindest. Von Marcelo, er ist ein Brasilianer, ist auch ein Lebermann, das kennt man von den Brasilianern. Das war aber schon immer so. Und ich denke, Marcelo, wenn man ihn die letzten zwei, drei Jahre beachtet, war mit Sicherheit unter dem Top-3 der Linksverteidigern. Vor allen Dingen in Offensiv, aber auch Defensiv immer eine Augenweide, auch technisch einfach unwahrscheinlich versiert. Und den hat er einfach komplett rausgenommen. Das ist für viele auch ein bisschen fraglich, vor allen Dingen dieser junge Reggie Lohnt, der da jetzt für ihn spielt meistens. Der macht seine Sache zwar gut, aber der hat natürlich keinerlei Erfahrungen in großen Spielen. Der hat auch gestern, finde ich, gegen Barcelona eigentlich in die Offensive hin, ein richtig tolles Spiel gemacht. In der Defensive mit Sicherheit schuld am 0-2, weil er da total falsch stand. Und ob das einem Marcello passiert, werde ich sagen, dahingestellt. Aber ich denke, bei Marcello ist es wie bei vielen anderen Spielern auch so. Da ist so ein bisschen, wie ich schon vorher gesagt habe, flapsig ein bisschen die Luft raus. Die sind alle ein bisschen ausgebrannt und geben vielleicht auch im Training nicht mehr 100 Prozent, sondern lassen es ein bisschen leichter angehen. Solari ist dann einfach knallhart und setzt die Jungs auf der Bank. Klar, ob das dann wirklich immer so der Vorteil ist für die Mannschaft, das ist dann natürlich eine andere Frage.
Also ich werde nicht so ganz aus Real schlau in dieser Saison, muss ich sagen. Wir haben zum einen das Spiel gegen Ajax, dass man 2 zu 1 gewonnen hat, das Hinspiel im Achtelfinale in Amsterdam. Durchaus glücklich, aber auch nicht komplett unverdient. Da war halt Real einfach das alte, clevere Champions League Real Madrid gegen, das man einfach nicht spielen möchte. Das wissen ja gerade auch die Anhänger des FC Bayern ganz gut. Dann hast du in der Liga das Stadtderby gegen Atletico, dass man bei Atletico mit 3 zu 1 gewinnt. Dann verlieren sie zu Hause gegen Girona 1 zu 2, gewinnen jetzt am Wochenende gegen Levante in der Liga durch zwei Strafstöße nach Rückstand, glaube ich. Es ist irgendwie eine diffuse Saison für Real. Wenn du jetzt mal die Gemengelage einordnen solltest, das hört sich so ein bisschen an nach einer Grundsatzfrage, ob der Trainer jetzt gestärkt wird von der Vereinsführung und dann eine Rotation im Kader einsetzt oder ob doch wieder eher der Trainer gewechselt wird und so mancher Spieler, der eben jetzt vielleicht auch nicht in seiner besten Form seiner Karriere ist, in der nächsten Saison doch mal einen weiteren Anlauf nimmt.
Also bei Real Madrid ist ganz klar, wer das sagen hat und das ist Präsident Florentino Pérez und der ist auch meistens verantwortlich für die großen Spielertransfers und man munkelt in Spanien unter anderem auch, dass Angelotti damals gehen musste, weil er Bale nicht genug Einsatzzeiten gegeben hat und Bale dann eben zu Pérez ging und gesagt hat, hey, so geht es nicht. Ja, dementsprechend ist die Trainerposition jetzt keine, die bei Real Madrid besonders gestärkt ist. Wenn es läuft, ist alles super. Wenn du Signe Rincidam bist und dreimal im Champions League holst, dann kannst du dir einiges erlauben. Aber normalerweise ist bei Florentino Pérez schnell Schluss mit lustig. Und die Geschichte mit Solari läuft sehr, sehr unglücklich. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass der Argentinier jetzt nicht so wirklich selbstkritisch ist und sich seiner zwar sehr sicher ist, aber gleichzeitig nicht die Ergebnisse liefert. Vor allen Dingen bekommt er keine gerade Linie rein, wie du schon gesagt hast. Man hat immer wieder zwischendurch das Gefühl, das läuft. Du hast dieses Champions League-Real, die müssen nicht viel machen, aber boom, hauen sie Ajax trotzdem in Amsterdam weg, ganz normal sozusagen. Und dann verlierst du in der Liga zuhause mit 1 zu 2 gegen Girona, obwohl du davor noch im Derby Atletico Madrid geschlagen hast, bei Atletico. Und gegen Levante, ganz ehrlich, der letzte Elfer-Max, das war überhaupt keiner. Also da hätten sie auch gut und gerne verlieren können oder zumindest ohne Gen spielen können. Es läuft nicht wirklich rund bei Real. Wir haben jetzt die Rückrunde, es ist vielleicht auch jetzt zu spät schon für den Trainerwechsel, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ja der Bock da jetzt noch groß umgestoßen wird, auch wenn viele Real-Fans immer noch auf die Champions League jetzt zumindest hoffen.
Ja klar, können sie ja auch aus guten Gründen.
Dementsprechend glaube ich wird es schwierig für Solari. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es bis Ende Saison hinbekommt, da wie gesagt noch eine gerade Linie reinzubringen und seine wie gesagt Kriegsschauplätze da irgendwie friedlich beenden kann. Das sehe ich im Moment nicht.
Gut, es ist ja auch beruhigend zu hören, dass sich wenigstens einige Dinge nicht geändert haben, also immer noch hat der Präsident alle Zügel in der Hand bei Real, was ja auch gar nicht so anders ist bei Barcelona, nur da haben wir jetzt eben komplett andere Vorzeichen. Die Liga wird immer noch angeführt von Barca mit 7 Punkten Vorsprung vor Atletico, 9 sind es eben schon auf Real vor dem Klassikoo jetzt am Wochenende. In der Champions League 0 zu 0 in Lyon gespielt, am Wochenende gegen Sevilla nach Rückstand. Messi, mal wieder Messi, da steht schon wieder bei 25 Toren nach 25 Spieltagen und 11 Assists, einfach unglaublich. Wie würdest du denn die Lage bei Barca einsortieren? Es sieht ja alles formal perfekt aus. Ist es denn auch so?
Ja, es herrscht schon auch ziemlich zumindest sportliche und taktische Kritik an dem FC Barcelona derzeit, weil man sich eigentlich einig ist, dass ohne Messi in den letzten Wochen nicht so viele Punkte geholt werden würden. Im Endeffekt ist es schon so, dass die Hinrunde sehr stark war. Vor allen Dingen hat man da auch einen Luis Suárez gesehen, der unwahrscheinlich viel geknipst hat. Der hat zwar gestern die Tore erzielt, aber der ist eigentlich in einem kleinen Formtief, hat in der Liga länger nicht mehr geknipst und überzeugt auch nicht mehr so. Die ganze Baselmannschaft steht ein bisschen in der Kritik, trotz der Tabellenposition. Weil man diese Inspiriertheit vermisst, weil das Spiel immer mehr oder weniger auf Messi zugeschnitten und auch abhängig von ihm ist. Es ist schon ein bisschen schade, finde ich zumindest, zu sehen, wenn man dann so ein Spiel hat wie Coutinho, der bei Liverpool ja überragend war und der bei Barca eigentlich überhaupt keine Rolle spielt. Oder zumindest nicht das zeigen kann, was er eben bei Liverpool gespielt hat. Das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen schade zu sehen. Dembélé hingegen macht seine Sache inzwischen ein bisschen besser. Der hat auch viel gemurrt am Anfang, weil er nicht so gespielt hat. Er ist auch disziplinär jetzt, er ist auch nicht der Bravste, wie man aus dortbunner Zeit schon weiß. Das hat den Katalaner auch nicht so gefallen. Aber ich denke, gestern hat er ein ziemlich starkes Spiel gemacht. Ich glaube, ein, zwei Tore auch vorbereitet. Na ja, also bei Barca ist man sich auch nicht so ganz einig im Moment, dass man in Top-Form ist. Das Spiel in Léon war jetzt auch wirklich nicht so gut. Aber man hat halt diesen Messi da vorne, mit seinen 25 Toren, el fascista, der dann immer noch einfach den Unterschied ausmachen kann, wenn es sein muss. Und darauf verlassen sich ein bisschen auch die Spieler. Und was man ganz und gar nicht vergessen darf, ist, finde ich, die Leistung von Marc Andritt, der jetzt im dritten Jahr bei Barca ist schon, dieses Jahr absolut überragend, das fast jede Woche von den Medien hier in Spanien über den Kläge lobt wird. Zu Recht auch. Der hat teilweise ein paar unmenschliche Paraden drauf. Gestern, das war noch relativ normal für ihn, aber der ist wirklich im Moment absolut in Top-Form und hat Barca mit Sicherheit in dieser Saison schon den einen oder anderen Punkt gerettet.
Ja, das ist auch wirklich erstaunlich, dass das in Deutschland gar nicht so wirklich ein Thema ist, dass sich Joachim Löw so klar auf Manuel Neuer in der Nationalmannschaft festlegt, der nun wirklich nicht gerade die Hochphase seiner Karriere aktuell hat, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Und vielleicht kommt er ja wieder zurück in die alte Form. Aber du hast einen deutschen Torhüter, der in einer der besten Ligen dieser Welt brilliert an jedem Wochenende. Also Barcelona hätte allein sieben Treffer mehr nach Expected Goals kassieren müssen, als sie es tatsächlich getan haben. Da hat auch Marc-Andre Ter Stegen seinen Anteil daran. Insgesamt sowieso ganz interessant, dass Barca eigentlich zehn Punkte weniger haben müsste, wenn es nach diesem statistischen Modell geht. Also sie würden aber trotzdem die Liga noch anführen. Übrigens vor Valencia, die werden nach Expected Points auf Platz zwei. Das finde ich ganz interessant. Da können wir dann gleich nochmal drüber sprechen. Denn in Wirklichkeit liegen sie ja auf Platz neun. Aber das ist wirklich ein interessantes Phänomen, das mag André ter Stegen. Obwohl es ja inzwischen auch über der Zone hier in Deutschland die Möglichkeit gibt, relativ viel La Liga zu sehen, dass das nicht so wirklich thematisiert wird, was für ein toller, deutscher Torhüter da spielt und dass der nie zum Zug kommt. Und zwar unwidersprochen nie. Also dass nicht mal gesagt wird, jetzt mal in ein paar Spielen darf er jetzt mal und dann vor dem nächsten Turnier entscheiden wir nochmal neu, sondern dass das einfach kategorisch ausgeschlossen wird.
Ja, da bin ich absolut bei dir, Max. Weil Manuel Neuer, du hast es selbst angesprochen, im Moment ist er nicht in der Form. Ich bin absolut auch Manuel Neuer Fan, schon immer gewesen. Einer der besten deutschen Torhüter jemals, wenn nicht vielleicht sogar der beste, aber eben vor zwei, drei, vier Jahren gewesen. Und im Moment ist das einfach, das muss man sportlich zumindest zu anerkennen, ist es der Stegen. Und dass da, ja, dass er gar keine Chancen bekommt, wie gesagt von Jachim Löw oder dass vielleicht auch die Medien in Deutschland ihn so ein bisschen vergessen ist, ein bisschen seltsam. Denn wie gesagt, bei Barca da so eine Leistung zu bringen über Jahre hinweg, so alt ist er auch noch nicht, also gebührt schon sehr viel Respekt. Und ist im Moment für mich tatsächlich formäßig der bessere deutsche Torhüter, ganz klar.
Naja, allein darüber könnte ich ewig diskutieren, aber das ist ja auch ein Vorteil dieser internationalen Kurzpass, dass man auf sowas noch mal wenigstens kurz hinweisen kann. Also Barca jetzt dann eben am Wochenende bei Real, haben wir jetzt denke ich häufig genug erwähnt. Sie werden mal gucken, ob sie jetzt haben sie das gezeigt, was sie gegen Lyon nicht gezeigt haben. Da war es so, dass Barca 25 Abschlüsse hatte und Lyon 5 und es ging 0 zu 0 aus. Jetzt im Copa del Rey Halbfinale war es genau umgedreht. Mal gucken, so ein Mittelding wäre glaube ich eine ganz gesunde Mischung für Barca. Zwischen Barca und Real Madrid haben wir dann jetzt schon seit Wochen Atletico sitzen, die jetzt zwar zu Hause das Derby verloren haben, aber dennoch mit zwei Punkten Vorsprung vor Real stehen. Sieben Rückstand auf Barca. Und was wahrscheinlich auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen haben, war vor allem der Champions League-Auftritt zu Hause gegen Juventus Turin, wo man sehr, sehr überzeugend gewonnen hat dann zu Hause mit 2 zu 0. Wie ist denn die Lage bei Atletico?
Ja, man hat bei Atletico immer so ein bisschen das Problem, dass man sich selbst gerne klein redet oder kleiner vielleicht als man ist. Und dass man eigentlich so immer das Gefühl hat, Atletico spielt eigentlich über seinen Verhältnissen. Die haben aber trotzdem natürlich Weltklasse-Spieler in ihren Reihen. Und sie haben einfach ein taktisches Konzept auferlegt bekommen von ihrem Trainer Diego Simeone, das vor allen Dingen erst mal so demütig ist und erst mal abwartend ist und die Gegner kommen lassen, aber natürlich gleichzeitig absolute Leidenschaft, Kampfesgeist und über diesen Weg dann quasi Richtung Tore und Richtung Sieg gestrebt wird. Und im Endeffekt tut es mir immer so ein bisschen weh, weil ich trotzdem bei Atletico Madrid sehr viele tolle Spieler sehe, die, glaube ich, viel mehr Lust hätten, auch ansehendlich in den Fußball zu spielen. Aber die Ergebnisse in den letzten Jahren geben Simeone dann ja doch immer wieder Recht und dementsprechend, ja, weiß ich auch nicht so genau. Man hat auf jeden Fall nicht das Gefühl, dass Atletico jemals oder zumindest in naher Zukunft aufschließen kann zu Barca und Real Madrid. Das ist finanziell natürlich auch nicht machbar, aber ich denke schon, dass man spielerisch eigentlich mehr von den Colchoneros, wie sie genannt werden, erwarten könnte. Vor allen Dingen ein Grießmann, finde ich, ist ein wahnsinnig überragender Fußballer, der allerdings viel zu selten an den Ball kommt und viel zu selten Leute um sich herum hat, mit denen er kombinieren oder spielen könnte. Dementsprechend verkauft sich Atletico immer gerne unter Wert, um dann solche Spiele, wie zum Beispiel Juventus, dann eben auch abzufeiern, weil keiner damit gerechnet hat, dass die 2-0 zu Hause vielleicht gegen Juve so klar gewinnen oder so gut spielen. Aber das ist ein bisschen auch das Konzept von Diego Simeone und seinem Team.
So ganz kriege ich Atletico nicht unter einen Hut, wenn man sich anguckt, was man in den Footballleagues alles über Atletico erfährt, wie die verstrickt sind in Vertragskonstrukte, die eigentlich ihnen die Hände binden. Wenn gewisse Spieler angefragt werden von anderen Vereinen, müssen sie die fast verkaufen. Die finanzielle Lage bei Atletico ist alles andere als rosig. Und trotzdem hatte man zum Beispiel in der Startelf gegen Juventus nur Spieler mit dabei, die schon seit minimum fünf Jahren – und das geht bis hoch zu 19 Jahren – bei Atletico, also in der Jugendmannschaft oder eben jetzt dann auch in der Profi-Mannschaft mit dabei sind. Also Koke ist schon 19 Jahre, aber wirklich egal, wen du da nimmst, Oblak fünf Jahre, Juanfran neun Jahre, Jimenez sechs Jahre, Godin neun Jahre, Luis acht Jahre. Also unglaublich eigentlich und kriegst man ja auch schon fünf Jahre mit dabei. Kannst du mir erklären, wie das Atletico trotz all dieser Widerstände – also finanzieller Natur und ja auch des Wettbewerbs, dass du mit Atletico bei einer Mannschaft spielst, wo du eigentlich keine Titel gewinnst in der Regel – wie schafft man das dann?
Atletico Madrid hat hier schon einen besonderen Start aus in Spanien. Man hat auch so einen gewissen Flair, einen gewissen Charme und so einen gewissen Ruf, der den Verein immer schon sehr beliebt gemacht hat. Und ja, ich glaube dieses Gefühl und dieses besondere Standing ist auch das, was der Trainer gerne an seine Spieler verkauft, der auch diesen Sommer übrigens Griezmann davon überzeugt hat, nicht zu Barca zu wechseln, sondern bei Atletico zu verlängern. Ich glaube im Moment beißt sich der Franzose dann ein bisschen selbst in dem Popo, dass er es nicht gemacht hat. Denn er merkt jetzt auch wieder, dass bei Atletico der Fortschritt nicht so wirklich da ist. Er möchte zwar Titel mit Atletico gewinnen, aber es ist halt doch nicht so ganz möglich. Trotzdem ist es richtig, was du sagst. Simone schafft es tatsächlich, eine eingeschworene Gemeinschaft zu gründen und diese auch zusammenzuschweißen. Und selbst wenn da mal einer dabei ist, der es dann nicht schafft, dann wird der wieder lieber verkauft, als dass man den mitzieht. Und ich glaube, das macht dann auch ein bisschen die Stärke aus von Atletico Madrid, dass man eben dieses gemeinschaftliche Team, diesen Team Spirit wirklich hat und dass wirklich der eine für den anderen kämpft. Und das ist ja im Endeffekt auch das, was dann auf dem Platz umgesetzt wird. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen immer schon dieses besondere Flair von Atletico gewesen, dass das eigentlich so zwar der nur der zweite Verein in Madrid ist, aber dass die Jungs viel mehr Herzblut haben und kämpfen. Und da passt natürlich Simeone mit seiner Einstellung, mit seinem, wie er so quasi den Fußballvorlieb perfekt rein. Und er schafft das wirklich, diese Spieler dort einzusperren und lange bei sich zu behalten. Interessante Geschichte vielleicht noch die Personale Lucas Hernández, der ja vom Bayern sehr ernsthaft kokettiert wird und wahrscheinlich auch wechselt wird. Da gab es dann ganz schnell Stimmen aus dem Verein, also beziehungsweise auch von den Spielern, von seinen Mitspielern, die dann gesagt haben, ja ok, wenn er halt zu Bayern will, dann soll er auch zu Bayern gehen und soll machen, was er will. Aber hier bei Atletico sind wir hier, Atletico 100 Prozent. Und wer nicht 100 Prozent bei uns ist, der kann sich gerne verdrücken sozusagen. Und das ist so ein bisschen die ganze Marke Atletico Madrid, die das so ein bisschen umschließt, sportlich wie auch in die Außendarstellung dann auch.
Was heißt denn Finale de Horm auf Spanisch?
Finale en la casa.
Ok, aber es gibt jetzt das noch nicht so als stehende Begriff, wie es damals hier in Deutschland war.
Es war vor allen Dingen, glaube ich, auch lange gar nicht so fix, dass die dann spielen können, denn das Wandermetropole, das glaube ich jetzt erst ein Jahr alt ist oder so, ist jetzt von Bau her nicht so ganz astrein. Und da gab es auch lange Zweifel, ob es dann wirklich dort stattfinden wird, was es jetzt aber tatsächlich tun wird. Nein, da wird nicht davon gesprochen. Ich glaube, man traut es Athletico nicht zu, wirklich im Finale zu stehen.
Ja, gut, ich meine, immerhin hat nach dem Europa League Triumph der Präsident Enrique Querezo genau das ausgerufen, das er gesagt hatte. So wie damals, einst Uli Hoeneß, da hat er sich an dem Größten orientiert, an dem man sich da orientieren kann. Das Finale, da müssen wir dabei sein, hat er dann eben auf Spanisch gesagt. Aber eigentlich wollte ich jetzt schon weitergehen, das interessiert mich jetzt, aber doch, du hast gesagt, da ist nicht alles astrein am Stadion. Wie meinst du das denn?
Im Stadion an sich, ja, der Bauer des Stadions, da gab es viele Probleme, da waren z.B. ich glaube, die sanitären Lagen waren nicht okay, da ist dann Wasser aus dem Klo rausgelaufen usw. usf. Also da gab es einfach viel Push am Bau und dementsprechend hat sich die UEFA da auch ein bisschen länger Zeit gelassen, dann dieses Stadion zu bestätigen, aber im Endeffekt haben wir es jetzt hinbekommen.
Na gut, wir werden das dann im Champions League Finale sehen, wer da dann stehen kann. Das waren die großen drei, über die immer gesprochen wird in den Kurzpässen zu La Liga, ein Team, über das wir bisher noch nicht so viel gesprochen haben, wo du mir jetzt aber vor der Aufnahme gesagt hast, da würdest du gerne mal ein bisschen draufgucken. Ist Athletic Bilbao, die stehen gerade auf Tabellenplatz 10, also so ein bisschen im grauen Mittelfeld. Warum ist es denn dir dennoch jetzt die Zeit wert, über Bilbao zu sprechen?
Na ich finde vor allen Dingen, glaube ich, Fußballromantiker finden die Geschichte um Athletic Bilbao sehr interessant. Es ist ein Verein, der so DINU-mäßig wie der HSV noch nie aus der 1. Liga abgestiegen ist, aber mit einer besonderen Vorgabe und zwar darf bei Athletic Bilbao, wie wahrscheinlich eh viele wissen, nur Baskenspielen und dementsprechend hat man natürlich jeden Sommer oder jeden Winter einen sehr, sehr beschränkten Transfermarkt. Und das Baskendal ist jetzt auch kein riesengroßes Land, so wie, weiß ich nicht, Bayern oder vielleicht hier in Spanien, Andalusien oder Katalonien, sondern es ist ziemlich klein. Ja, und das macht den Markt tatsächlich dann sehr, sehr gering, was die Kaderplanung anbelangt. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber der ganze Stolz einer ganzen Region und für jeden Spieler, der bei Athletic Bilbao spielt, ist es dementsprechend was ganz, ganz Besonderes. Und ja, ich finde es einfach faszinierend, dass ein Verein, der sich selbst durch die Politik so eine Beschränktheit auferlegt, es schafft jedes Mal tatsächlich die Liga nicht nur zu halten, sondern teilweise ja auch international dabei, weil ich glaube, es ist nicht allzu lang her, da waren sie in der Europa League mit, ich kann mich an ein Duell erinnern mit Manchester United und so weiter. Also das ist schon, das ist schon was ganz Besonderes. Und dazu muss man auch sagen, die allerbesten Basken, die spielen ja gar nicht bei Athletic, weil die gehen dann auch zu Real Madrid oder nach England, Xavier Alonso zum Beispiel, um mal ein Beispiel zu nennen oder so. Ja und dementsprechend muss ich sagen, ist das ein Verein, der wirklich, ja wie gesagt, für so Fußballromantiker und ich bin da gerne auch dabei in dieser Gruppe, sag ich jetzt mal, finde ich das sehr schön. Ich glaube, jeder würde sich freuen, zum Beispiel, wenn der FC Bayern nur mit Spielern aus Bayern zurechtkommen würde, dann wäre der FC Bayern mit Sicherheit nicht da, wo er im Moment ist. Aber vom Grundgedanken her ist es wie gesagt so eine romantische Auslegung und die ziehen das wirklich seit Bestehen hier durch und finde ich wie gesagt sehr interessant. Und dazu kommt ja noch, dass man sich immer wieder auch internationale Trainer leistet. Wir können uns ja alle an Jupp Heynckes erinnern, der auch immer gerne über Bilbao spricht, der von einer besonderen Zeit dort spricht. Ich finde, der Club hat einfach etwas ganz Besonderes in Spanien und dementsprechend wollte ich das einfach nur mal erwähnen.
Also neben Jupp Heynckes und unter anderem auch Marcelo Biel ist er für zwei Spielzeiten in Bilbao und Ernesto Valverde, an denen werden sich vielleicht noch mehr erinnern. Und das ist das tatsächlich Interessante, dass Bilbao neben dem Fakt, dass sie noch nie abgestiegen sind aus der ersten Liga, eben auch wirklich gute Platzierungen hatten. Also wenn ich mal gucke, 2013, 14 Platz 4, 14, 15, 7, Platz 5, Platz 7. Dann eine Saison, in der es um den Abstieg ging, 2017, 2018 haben vielleicht auch der ein und die ein oder andere mitbekommen. Und in dieser Saison sieht es eben so aus, als würde das eine angenehm langweilige Saison werden aus den letzten sechs Ligaspielen. Nur eine Niederlage, zwei Unentschieden und drei Siege. Man hat aktuell zehn Punkte Vorsprung auf die Abstiegs-Ränge. Also sieht es nach einer ganz ruhigen, angenehmen Bilbao-Saison aktuell aus.
Man hat ja sogar noch die Chance. Platz vier ist ja nur sechs Punkte weg. Man hat in La Liga ja extremes Gefälle zwischen Rang Vier oder die ersten drei und dann von Rang Vier bis Rang, weiß ich nicht, 14, 15, glaube ich, sind es nur neun Punkte. Also da kann noch einiges passieren, aber natürlich auch nach unten. Also da ist eine große Ausgeglichenheit dieses Jahr in Spanien vorhanden und für Athletik kann es dementsprechend auch ganz schnell nach oben, aber auch wieder ganz schnell nach unten gehen. Also die müssen schon aufpassen.
Das ist mir auch in dieser Saison besonders aufgefallen. Es gibt keine Mannschaft, so wirklich, wenn wir jetzt eben mal die großen drei ausblenden, die mal so eine richtige Siegesserie hätte starten können. Es gibt ganz, ganz viele Unentschieden. Da ist Valencia auch so der einsame Spitzenreiter mit seinen 15 Unentschieden aus 25 Spielen. Aber ist das auch einer der Gründe für die Ausgeglichenheit, dass es da keiner aus der Mittelfeld-Mannschaft, vier, fünf, sechs Siege aneinander zu rein und sich damit ein bisschen abzusetzen?
Ja, vor allen Dingen auch sehr überraschend, wie ich finde, dass das tatsächlich so ist. Weil Sevilla oder Valencia, wie du schon angesprochen hast, die haben eigentlich schon einen Kader, wo man sagen könnte, du könntest es eigentlich schon besser als die unteren 10, 12, 13, 14 Mannschaften. Und da könnte man eigentlich schon mal eine Siegesserie erwarten. Aber auch die kleineren Vereine in Spanien leisten sehr, sehr gute Arbeit in den letzten Jahren. Und ja, vor allen Dingen haben viele Trainer auch im taktischen Bereich sehr viel gute Arbeit geleistet bei den kleinen Clubs. Wenn man zum Beispiel sieht Deportivo Alaves an Tabellenposition 6, ist eigentlich total irrsinnig oder getaffe auf Platz 4. Also da sind wirklich ein paar ordentliche Fußballlehrer im Moment am Start, die diese kleinen Clubs ganz gut bewegen können. Sie haben natürlich auch den Vorteil, dass sie nicht so diesen Medienrummel um sich rum haben und sie können sich tatsächlich wirklich auf Sportliche konzentrieren. Bei Valencia ist immer Chaos, ist immer Toho Mabohu. Dementsprechend wird es auch immer schwer werden, dort für den Trainer zu arbeiten, obwohl die Voraussetzungen eigentlich a priori sehr gut sind. Es ist im Moment wirklich so in Spanien, dass eine sehr große Ausgeglichenheit herrscht, ausgenommen mit den drei oberen Mannschaften. Es überrascht so ein bisschen. Wie gesagt, es gibt schon ein paar Teams wie Valencia, vielleicht auch Betis, die eigentlich noch so ein bisschen über den anderen stehen sollten. Aber im Moment ist eher so das Prinzip, dass fast jeder jeden schlagen kann, bis auf die ersten drei natürlich.
Ja, und falls ihr euch fragt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schießt denn Valencia inzwischen Tore? Denn das hatten wir schon mal im Rasenfunk thematisiert, dass das einer der Gründe für die vielen Unentschieden ist. Nein, aktuell 25 Tore nach 25 Spieltagen. Da hat sich nichts verändert. Und wenn wir jetzt schon so ein bisschen das größere Bild dieser Liga zeichnen, dann kommt ja auch mit dazu, dass wir aktuell in der 2. Liga, die du ja mit deinem Bezug zum Malaga, zu dem du uns auch gleich dann am Schluss noch ein bisschen was erzählen darfst, näher verfolgst. Da finden wir gerade Namen wie eben Malaga, Deportivo La Coruña und noch so manch andere klangvoller Name, der vielen Hörern und Hörern noch bewusst sein sollte. Und dafür gibt es viele Vereine in der 1. Liga, wie zum Beispiel Huesca oder Chirona oder auch Leganes, mit denen man jetzt weniger anfangen konnte. Du hast im Vorgespräch gesagt, das sind Teams, die vielleicht gar nicht wirklich dahingehören. Wie hast du das denn gemeint?
Ja, es ist schon so, dass es sich bei vielen Klubs jetzt nicht wirklich um die großen Traditionsvereine in Spanien handelt, um jetzt mal diesen Begriff Traditionsverein rauszuholen, der in Deutschland, glaube ich, auch immer ganz gerne diskutiert wird, wenn es um Leipzig und so weiter geht. Nein, es ist wirklich so, dass das Huesca einen Durchmarsch, glaube ich, geschafft hat von der 4. 3. 2. 1.
Liga.
Also die haben natürlich hervorragend gearbeitet, aber das ist eigentlich ein Club, der da nicht hingehört und der wahrscheinlich auch mit ziemlicher Sicherheit auch absteigen wird.
Und wie haben die das geschafft? Also wenn du sagst, hervorragend gearbeitet, hatten die dann auch einen Geldgeber oder haben die einen anderen Vorteil? Irgendwie muss das ja geklappt haben. Oder ist das so ein Darmstadt-Durchmarsch, wo man nicht so ganz genau weiß, wie es passiert ist und dann war es irgendwann auch wieder vorbei?
Ja, ich glaube, es geht eher so Richtung Darmstadt. Also sie haben tatsächlich mit relativ geringen finanziellen Mitteln immer es geschafft, ein gutes Team zu stellen in der zweiten Liga, die in Spanien sowieso sehr, sehr ausgeglichen ist. Kannst du einfach, wenn du Lauf hast, auch mit einem mittelmäßigen Team den Aufstieg schaffen. Das, glaube ich, ist bei Wesker passiert. Und im Moment zahlen sie im Moment so ein bisschen den Zoll dafür. Also die Qualität in der ersten Liga reicht vom Team her eigentlich nicht aus. Trotzdem, finde ich, machen sie es ganz gut, schlagen sich ganz ordentlich, haben immerhin 19 Punkte, sind zwar tabellenletzter, aber haben den einen oder anderen Verein schon ganz ordentlich geärgert. Ja, und Liganes ist ein Madridter Vorstadt-Club, der auch so irgendwie aus dem Nichts kam und sich hochgearbeitet hat in die zweite und dann in die erste Liga. Inzwischen wird er übrigens von einer Frau geführt, also die ist Präsidentin und hat sehr gute Beziehungen zur Wirtschaft. Dementsprechend macht sie das auch sehr gut, in der Hinsicht, dass sie sich immer gute, junge Spieler holt oder Spieler, die vielleicht bei den großen Teams nicht rankommen, die werden dann ausgeliehen. Dann brauchst du den richtigen Trainer, der dann noch ein Team zusammen formt und das geht hin. Gelingt Liganes ist jetzt schon im zweiten oder dritten Jahr in Folge in der ersten Liga. Das Konzept ist ja eigentlich auch so bekannt, dass man sich quasi unzufriedene Spieler mit viel Talent von größeren Vereinen holt und ihnen dann einen Schauplatz gibt und so jetzt mach mal und zeig der Welt mal, was du drauf hast. Das funktioniert bei vielen dieser Clubs. Eibar ist vielleicht auch einer, der dahingehört, der auch jedes Jahr eigentlich die besten Spieler verliert und dann immer schauen muss, was er dann so wieder noch bekommt auf dem Transfermarkt, aber sich dann trotzdem irgendwie schaffen. Wahrscheinlich auch, weil sie in Ruhe arbeiten können, gute Übungsleiter haben, dann ein ordentliches Team zu formen und sich dann in der ersten Liga zu halten. Aber es sind viele Teams dabei, die erwartet man oder sieht man oder kennt man eigentlich gar nicht aus der ersten Liga. Und sie schaffen es zumindest im Moment, dass dort eine sehr große Ausgeglichenheit besteht. Aber irgendwie ist auch so ein bisschen das Flair dieses Jahr verloren gegangen, hat man so das Gefühl, zumindest in Spanien.
Okay, und dann ist es ja auch so für jeden Verein, der in der ersten Liga irgendwie neu seinen Platz gefunden hat und sich dort behauptet, gibt es ja auch einen Verein, der es vielleicht eher gewohnt war, mal in der ersten Liga zu spielen, der jetzt in der zweiten Liga sich bewegt. Lass mal über Malaga und Co. sprechen, weil du eben da auch deinen Schwerpunkt hast. Wir in Deutschland rühmen uns ja immer für unsere 2. Bundesliga, die auch in diesem Jahr wieder relativ spannend ist. Und mit dem HSV und dem 1. FC Köln ja auch zwei namhafte Absteiger jetzt aufnehmen dürfte. Meinst du, die Deutschen haben die beste 2. Liga aller Zeiten oder müssen wir da nicht vielleicht die Segundadivision auch in die Rechnung mit reinnehmen?
Ja, die ist schon ziemlich gut. Also ich würde mal ganz gerne einen Vergleich ziehen. Zum Beispiel ein FC Malaga mal gegen Köln oder ein Deportivo La Coruña vielleicht gegen den HSV und so. Wäre interessant. Im Allgemeinen ist es ja schon so, dass der spanische Fußball technisch definitiv versierter ist als vielleicht der deutsche. Dafür ist der deutsche vielleicht laufstärker, vielleicht auch vom Einsatz her ein bisschen stärker. Es wären interessante Duele, denke ich, mal auf dieser Ebene. Die zweite Liga in Spanien ist ja so eine Mammutliga mit 22 Teams. Man hat hier extrem viele Spiele und leider ist es keine sehr ansinnliche Liga. Ich habe vor kurzem mal einen Ausschnitt gesehen, ich weiß nicht, um was, Holstein, Kiel oder so. Die spielten ja wie Barcelona zur besten Guardiola-Zeiten. Eine unglaubliche Kombination.
Sobald die nicht repräsentativ für die zweite Liga stehen, keine Angst.
Okay, okay, da habe ich mich schon gewundert, was ist denn in Deutschland los?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das siehst du in der zweiten Liga in Spanien nicht. Das sind ganz, ganz enge Kistnehmer, die gehen 0 zu 0 aus, 1 zu 0, 1 zu 1, 0 zu 1. Also da passieren nicht viele Tore, da passieren nicht viele Torchancen. Es ist wirklich ein richtig harter, zerfleischender Überlebenskampf. Und wenn man sich die Liga im Moment mal anzieht, dann sieht man auch, wie eng das alles zusammen ist. Also ich glaube zwischen Platz 1 und Platz 5 sind es, glaube ich, drei Punkte insgesamt. Und danach sind auch im Mittelfeld ganz viele Teams ganz eng zusammen. Also es ist eine sehr starke Liga, wie ich finde. Es ist eine sehr schwere Liga. Dort wirklich zu gewinnen, egal ob es gegen den Ersten oder gegen den Letzten ist, ist immer sehr, sehr, sehr hart, weil die Mannschaften eigentlich erst mal darauf fixiert sind, die Null zu halten und dann vorne immer gucken, ob wir irgendwie einen rein drücken. Dementsprechend ist es auch wirklich, wie gesagt, nicht sehr anziehendlich ein Fußball, aber trotzdem qualitativ, denke ich, sind die Teams schon sehr, sehr gut aufgestellt. Und wie gesagt, technisch sind die Spanier sowieso von Geburt an, weiß ich nicht, haben die ein anderes Gefühl zum Ball als vielleicht wir Deutschen. Das siehst du auf jedem Polzplatz, du kannst hier irgendwie mit den Jungs kicken gehen und dann steht da so ein kleiner Dicker da und du denkst dir, ja okay, da muss ich mir keine Sorgen machen, da gehe ich locker dran vorbei. Und dann hat er den Ball und zaubert trotzdem damit. Also das können sie alle irgendwie. Und ich denke, das zeichnet im spanischen Fußball auch einfach aus, dass diese Technik schon noch was ganz besonderes ist. Und das sieht man auch in der 2. Liga, obwohl, wie gesagt, der Spiel an sich jetzt nicht so mit Highlights gespickt ist.
Und wie ist dann die Situation beim FC Malaga? Vielleicht erinnern sich die Hörer vielleicht noch daran, 2011, 2012, Vierter geworden mit Trainer Manuel Pellegrini in der 1. Liga, wohlgemerkt. Und jetzt eben aktuell in der 2. Liga auf Tabellenplatz 2, wenn ich es richtig sehe, genau 2. hinter Osasuna und vor Deportivo La Coruña.
Ja, es ist schwierig bei uns geworden, Max, denn wir haben 2010 ja einen Scheich als Präsidenten bekommen, als Investor sozusagen.
Und dann wurde nicht alles besser. Ich dachte, dann wird immer alles besser.
Kurzfristig wurde es besser, aber langfristig sind wir jetzt hier mit der 2. Liga. Also von daher ist die Geschichte jetzt auch schon so ganz kurz schnell erzählt. Nee, er hat am Anfang viel Geld in den Verein gesteckt, du hast das angesprochen. Champions League war möglich in der Saison 2012, 2013 mit Pellegrini. Es gab dieses unwahrscheinliche Viertelfinale gegen den BVB. Das war, glaube ich, meine einzigste Auswärtsreise, die ich mit dem FC Malaga gemacht habe, damals im Signal Iduna Park oder Westfalenstaden, wie ich es lieber nenne. Und es war hervorragende Stimmung und das Spiel war Wahnsinn. Und Malaga hat eigentlich dort ganz klar verdient, weiterzukommen. Aber Malaga hatte auch zu dieser Zeit schon extreme finanzielle Probleme. Spielergehälter wurden nicht gezahlt. Es gab unwahrscheinlich viele Schulden bezüglich oder in sich des Finanzamtes. Und die UEFA hat es alles so mit einem Augesaugen beachtet und war dem FC Malaga nicht gesonnen. Und man muntet auch in Analysien so, dass dementsprechend auch vielleicht die ein oder andere Entscheidung am Schluss des Spiels gegen den FC Malaga ausgelegt worden ist.
Damals in diesem BVB-Spiel, wo es dieses klare Upside gab. Okay, interessant.
Genau. Malaga war sogar vorne bis in die Schlussphase. In der Nachspielzeit hat der BVB zwei Tore geschossen. Und vor allem das zweite war irgendwie…
Da standen irgendwie sechs oder sieben Spieler im Upside.
Genau. Dementsprechend war das ziemlich klar, dass das Upside war. Aber gut, man ist hier nach wie vor nicht so gut auf den BVB zu sprechen in Analysien. Weil er natürlich am wenigsten wahrscheinlich dafür kann. Naja, auf jeden Fall hat der Schalke dann leider sein Interesse verloren an seinem Spielzeug. Wenn ich das mal so nennen darf, hat aufgehört zu investieren. War stinksauer auf alle möglichen Verantwortlichen. Und dementsprechend musste jeder Sportdirektor, der sich dann erbarmt hat, den Verein zu übernehmen, die besten Spieler, die besten Loa werden eben verkaufen. Und um sich so über Wasser zu halten. Und so ging es eben Stück für Stück runter. Man hat noch lange geschafft, in der ersten Liga sich zu halten. Man hat unter anderem auch gute Trainer gehabt. Zum Beispiel Javi Gracia, der jetzt bei Watford ist und eine sehr gute Saison spielt in England. Also man hat auch immer wieder das Glück gehabt, gute Trainer zu holen, gute Sportdirektor. Weil eben Wallach an Traditionsverein ist, die Leute nach wie vor oder die Verantwortlichen nach wie vor anziehen, obwohl man über die Schwierigkeit Bescheid weiß mit dem Schalch. Und Bernd Schuster war sogar kurzfristig mal da. Der hat dann aber auch schnell gemerkt, dass es eigentlich beim FC Maler gar nicht mehr viel zu holen gibt. Naja, und letztlich sind wir dann letztes Jahr sang- und klanglos abgestiegen in die 2. Liga. Und ja, haben es zumindest jetzt geschafft, nach diesen extremen finanziellen prekären Lagen, in der wir waren, den Schulden bergab zu bauen. Es ist nicht mehr viel da, es ist ein gesunder Verein inzwischen, der versucht, sich wieder nach vorne zu boxen. Wir haben seit diesem Jahr einen neuen Sportdirektor mit Kamminero, der vorher bei Atletico Madrid, unter anderem mit Diego Simeone gearbeitet hat. Der macht einen ganz ordentlichen Job, allerdings… Gute Frage, haben wir uns auch alle gestellt und uns gewundert. Aber ich glaube schon, dass Malaga nach wie vor diesen gewissen Flair hat. Es ist hier eine Fußballstadt, es sind hier 600.000 Einwohner. Es ist eine Fan-Kultur hier, die das Stadion – ja, das ist 230.000 Zuschauer groß, aber das kriegen sie immer relativ gut voll. Das ist in Spanien übrigens nicht oft der Fall. Also, man sieht viele Erstleger-Spiele mit relativ leeren Rängen. Die Preispolitik in Spanien ist ziemlich verrückt und ist dafür auch mitverantwortlich. Aber ja, man hat hier einfach eine gute Struktur, eine gute Basis. Und theoretisch könnte man aus dem FC Malaga wieder einen richtig guten Erstleger-Club machen, vielleicht sogar mit Aspiration auf europäische Bühne. Allerdings hat man immer wieder das Problem mit dem Schalke, dass er eben aus Katar leider meistens dazwischenfunkt und sehr, sehr komische Entscheidungen trifft, den Geld zudreht, Spieler kauft auch, die ihm angeboten werden über YouTube. Da gab es mal ein Marokkanisches Talent, das ihm irgendjemand erzählt hat, den er kaufen muss für 250.000 Euro oder so, das wirklich viel Geld auch ist in Spanien, das 2. Liga, da könnte man richtig gestanden einen Spieler für bekommen. Den hat er geholt im Sommer und der ist jetzt nicht mal mehr gut genug für das 2. Team des FC Malaga, der jetzt hier in der Regionalliga spielt und sie kriegen ihn im Moment nicht los. Also aus Argentinien hat er sich auch ein paar Talente aufschwarzen lassen. Cetini für 5 Millionen Euro, weil er angeblich in Interhau haben wollte, der ist inzwischen wieder zurück in Argentinien. Also wir können nicht ganz professionell arbeiten, dadurch, dass aus Katar immer leichte Störfeuer kommen.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich mal ein Tribünengespräch zu 50 plus 1 machen. Cinquenta, Iuno, wie es bei euch heißen müsste. Aber ich glaube, das kann ich mir langsam sparen. In diesen internationalen Kurzpassen gibt es immer so viele Beispiele dafür, wie eben nicht alles besser wurde durch Investoren, sondern wie eben genau das eintritt, was zu erwarten ist. Nämlich, dass auch Leute kommen, die das als Spielzeug begreifen und dann das Wohl und Wehe eines kompletten Vereins davon abhängt, dass irgendjemand den Daumen hebt oder senkt und dann eben auch so komische Dinge passieren. Und vor allem, ich habe mir noch mal diese 2011er-2012er-Mannschaft angeguckt. Das ist ja Wahnsinn, wer damals mit dabei war. Caballero, der inzwischen jetzt andere Schlagzeilen gerade bei Chelsea machen darf. Nacho Monreal, damals 25. Eliseo war mit dabei. Martin de Miquel ist ja sowieso. Joris Mattheisen, das waren die Innenverteidiger. Dann hattest du einen 19-jährigen Isco, einen 21-jährigen Camacho, der ja bei Wolfsburg inzwischen gelandet ist. Wie wir alle wissen, Jérémy Thoulain hat noch mitgespielt. Unglaublich, du da noch vorne drin. Rued van Nisselrooy natürlich noch. Meine Güte, was für eine Mannschaft.
Ich bin 2006 nach Malaga gekommen, Max. Da war Zweitligafußball. Ich habe diesen Verein quasi so übernommen und kennengelernt. Plötzlich, vier Jahre später, kommt ein Scheich und stellt mir diese Spieler hin, die ich noch aus meinen Zeiten aus München kannte. Demike Lesar und Gesonter Cruz. Und ich spiele plötzlich hier bei mir ums Eck Fußball. Was hier los war, war unglaublich. Aber wie du schon gesagt hast, leider ist dieser Daumen-hoch-Daumen-runter-Zeiger tatsächlich so. Und leider ist es bei uns auch noch der Fall, dass wir einen Scheich haben, der zwar auch zur katarischen Königsfamilie gehört, wo ja auch der von Paris Saint-Germain gehört ist. Ich glaube, die sind irgendwie Croissants oder so. Aber leider ist unser Scheich vom Fußballverstand her ganz weit weg von der Realität.
Ach, Wahnsinn. Malaga. Das war jetzt echt nochmal ein schöner Ausflug, auch in alte Zeiten nochmal so ein bisschen. Deswegen habe ich es jetzt nochmal erwähnt, weil ich mich einfach so gefreut habe, nochmal mir diesen Kader anzugucken. Und ich grüße ganz herzlich den Ed Big Easy Muck, der einzige mir bekannte Malaga-Fan aus Deutschland, der auf Twitter aktiv ist. Vielleicht hört er das ja hier. Der hat immer Martin Dimikilis sehr gefeiert. Ja, Fabian, ich danke dir sehr. Das war sehr interessant. Das nächste Mal machen wir vielleicht mal nur 2. Das finde ich fast spannender, weil irgendwie kriegt man ja dann die wichtigen Themen, kriegt man ja dann doch irgendwie mit in der La Liga, in der 1. Liga. Danke dir, dass du mal mit im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst. Ja, machen wir sehr gerne wieder. EttRosengartler heißt Fabian auf Twitter. Folgt ihm da, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und euch herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 119. Es gibt in der Nacht auf Montag natürlich die nächste Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga. Es wird auch Tribütengespräche geben im März. Und mal gucken, was dann als nächstes so im Kurzpass hier aufschlagen wird. Ach ja, nee, doch, ich weiß es schon. Na, da kommt noch was Nettes auf euch zu, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Freut euch. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Zeit.